this is why you don't insult the robots
because they will take their vengeance
like a terminator themed rodeo this man
is being thrown around like a rag doll
but how these guys created a wild ride
with a robot
the programmers have designed a specific
path here to give this guy a wild ride
what's really amazing about this robot
is that it can pull off all these tasks
with the accuracy of a thousandth of an
inch that's tenths of a millimeter it
may look like fun but is this wild ride
synth the most dangerous thing here is
not that the robot would somehow
malfunction but that the programmer have
entered a bad program and the danger
lies in the rapid accelerations and
decelerations the most likely risk that
he faces is actually whiplash where the
bottom of the spine gets pulled in one
direction in the top of the spine and
gets pulled in the other creating an
s-curve and this can really damage or
strain ligaments in the neck if you do
have access to a large robot arm like
this do not try this yourself